- No one really liked me, because of,
because of the old man smell, so I wasn't
really close to any of the people there.
(squeaking)
(upbeat music)
I was working on Bernie Mac,
and Ken Kwapis, the director, came on,
he was a big fan of my
band The Grassroots,
so I heard that he was
doing the show The Office.
I shot my own talking head,
presented it to Greg Daniels,
and they gave me the Halloween episode
with Steve Carell and
the rest, as they say,
in the books.
Because it's such a great name.
I trolled.
Did a lot of trolling for people
who didn't really want me there.
The character guy, he's in the fray,
he says, "I can't believe he's making
"all that music with just his mouth."
I went in the other
room with the director,
I says, "why don't you just
"come on close to me
and, you don't have to,
"leave it out of focus," I said,
"and I'll go, 'That's what she said.'"
And he says, "I don't, can't believe
"you made all that music
with just his mouth."
And they come in,
"that's what she said."
People missed the first two times.
The third time of
viewing, then they saw it.
It was pretty much wasted.
In the sixties I made love to
many, many women, often outdoors
in the rain and the mud.
It's possible a man slipped in.
There'd be no way of knowing.
Ba-da-boom!
John Krasinski, when we were doing,
we'd do the scenes, he suggested
we do it like a David Mamet play.
If you notice that one scene,
I think it's Survivor Man, but we're both
in each other's face, like just going,
(rolling tongue)
just rapid fire stuff, and it was so,
it turned out so much fun.
I was at the trial when
Toby was up there testifying
with blood all over me, with the parents
of the victims and stuff,
bereaved, the press,
nobody noticed me.
No one saw me there.
No one paid any attention.
They got the wrong guy.
- [Director] So was Creed
the Scranton Strangler?
(music stops)
- Next question please.
Bert.
Bert Jacobs.
Really good worm guy out in Pennsylvania.
Well, he was selling weapons grade drugs
to kids besides IDs, military weapons,
he had a slave trade
trafficking thing going on,
there were so many things we
were gonna bring up, you know.
His father was found out to be an alien.
That I asked Creed the other day, I said,
"did you really kill me?"
And he hemmed and hawed for a long time,
and uh, I really couldn't get,
I really haven't got a
straight answer out of him
and any of my personalities
about this thing.
It's a quandary to be very honest.
Kept my trailer, kept all my wardrobe,
I kept some cameras, sound equipment.
When I came over recently to
visit the old sound stage,
you know, they had, you know,
an indictment against me,
basically.
So I really can't go back there anymore.
I was over in Romania for a while,
shooting this noir Western
called The Sister Brothers.
I'll be going on tour
to promote my new album
While the Young Punks Dance.
He'd probably escape,
obviously, right away
from the Scranton police,
so he's probably off under an assumed name
doing the same thing he always did:
fishing, living in Canada,
going back and forth, you know,
selling drugs, killing people.
Just having a really good life.
(upbeat music continues)
(squeaking)